hey everyone it's Sarah threats Turner  sorry and calm and in this video I'm  going to show you how to doff or take  off an n95 respirator now it's a Dolph  or take off the mask  two things you want to remember is that  you don't want to touch the front of the  mask because it's considered  contaminated but you can touch the  straps of the mask because these are  considered clean first you will take  your hands and you will remove the  bottom strap by pulling it over the head  then you will take the top strap and  pull it over the head be very careful  not to touch the mask now you can  dispose or reuse the mask depending on  your facility's protocol and then  perform hand hygiene okay so that wraps  up this review on how to doll for take  off an n95 respirator and don't forget  to check out the other videos in this  nursing skills series